LAST TIME SEEING DAK HE WAS
BEING CARTED OFF THE FIELD.
STEVE: COULD HELP GOVERNOR
NEWSOM IN RECALL BATTLE BY
MOVING VOTING DATE.
LOS ANGELES RESTAURANT OWNER AND
VOCAL CRITIC OF THE GOVERNOR
SINCE THE BEGINNING OF THE STATE
SEVERE LOCKDOWN RULES.
CHEF ANDREW FROM FLATFISH
RESTAURANT JOINS US RIGHT NOW
FROM CALIFORNIA.
CHEF, GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
>> WELL, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
HAVING ME.
I REALLY APPRECIATE IT AND
HOPEFULLY ONE OF THESE DAYS, ONE
OF THESE MORNINGS WE WILL BE
TALKING PANCAKES AS OPPOSED TO
NEWS OF MONARCHY.
[LAUGHTER]
STEVE: LET’S TALK ABOUT RECALL,
HOW ARE THE DEMOCRATS TRYING TO
HELP THEIR GOVERNOR?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, I HAVE TO
SAY WHEN I WAS -- I WAS JUST
SCROLLING THROUGH, I THINK, IT
WAS TWITTER WHEN I SAW THIS
HEADLINE AND I HONESTLY BELIEVED
THIS WAS SATIRE AND NEWSOM IS
TRYING TO USE THE POWER.
THEY ARE MOVING THE ELECTION UP
OR THE RECALL UP AND, LOOK, EVEN
TRAIN TO PUT THE KIND OF
PARTISAN POLITICS AND
SPECULATION ASIDE, I THINK
ANYBODY IN THEIR RIGHT MIND WHO
WOULD SEE THIS WOULD RECOGNIZE,
WHOA, WHOA.
SOMETHING IS NOT RIGHT HERE.
IF YOU HAVE PRETTY MUCH ABSOLUTE
POWER AND YOU’RE USING THAT IN
ORDER TO MANIPULATE OR, YOU
KNOW, RELITIGATE THE RULES UNDER
WHICH YOUR OWN RECALL IS BEING
RUN.
I MEAN, THAT IS JUST NOT THE
OPTICS ALONE ARE DIRTY.
STEVE: FOR SURE.
LET’S JUST GET THIS OVER WITH
REAL CLICK.
BELIEVE IT OR NOT, EVEN THOUGH
HE’S ENACTED SUCH RESTRICTIVE
RULES DURING THE PANDEMIC, HIS
POPULARITY IS INCHING UP A
LITTLE BIT.
I KNOW THEY HAVE PLENTY OF
SIGNATURES COLLECTED OVER THE
RECALL OVER NORTH OF 1.7 MILLION
WHICH IS ALL -- IT’S ABOUT BUT
SOME SAY THE LONGER THE WAIT, IT
COULD ACTUALLY ALLOW FOR NEW
PROBLEMS TO POP UP AND THAT
WOULD ACTUALLY HELP YOUR SIDE.
>> YEAH, 100%.
I THINK THE REASON AND THIS IS
JUST MY OPINION THAT THINGS ARE
OKAY RIGHT NOW, BUSINESSES ARE
OPENING, YOU KNOW, PEOPLE HAVE A
LITTLE BIT OF MONEY IN THEIR
POCKET AND OBVIOUSLY, YOU KNOW,
BY VIRTUE OF A LOT OF MONEY
BEING PRINTED FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND IF HE MOVES I
SPECULATE -- THEY MIGHT SHUT US
DOWN AGAIN AND THEY NEED TO TAKE
CARE WHILE THE NUMBERS ARE LOW
AND THAT’S WHERE THINGS GET
SCARY FROM MY PERSPECTIVE.
STEVE: APPARENTLY THEY ARE
SAYING IN LA COUNTY THEY ARE
SUGGESTING THAT PEOPLE MASK UP
AGAIN IN RESTAURANTS.
IF THEY’RE ASKING PEOPLE TO DO
THAT BECAUSE OF THE INDIAN,
DELTA VARIANT.
THEY MIGHT SAY WE WILL HAVE TO
CLOSE DOWN THE RESTAURANTS AGAIN
AND THAT’S WHERE YOUR BIGGEST
WORRY IS.
>> EXACTLY.
THAT’S WHAT I KEEP TALKING
ABOUT.
LOOK, WITH THE LABOR
CONVERSATION HAS BEEN HUGE IN
MEDIA OUTLET AND PART OF THE
REASON PEOPLE DON’T WANT TO COME
BACK TO WORK, OPEN CLOSE, OPEN
CLOSE AND THEY ARE ANXIOUS OF A
POTENTIAL SHUTDOWN AND HEAR
ABOUT MASK MANDATES AND THEY
NEWSOM IS MOVING THE RECALL TO
SWEET SPOT.
THINGS ARE FISHY, TO USE MY OWN
PUNT.
STEVE: FLATFISH RESTAURANT.
ANDREW, THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
GETTING UP SO EARLY.